wir alle wollen natürlich gemeinsam
rausfinden die meistgestellte Frage wann
ist der Zeitpunkt wo es aus dem Krieg in
ja an die verhandlungsstische geht wann
ist dieser Zeitpunkt gekommen was würden
Sie im Moment sagen ganz kurzer Antwort
vielleicht einmal die Runde heute was
ist dieser Zeitpunkt also wann geht es
von beiden Seiten an Verhandlungstisch
dann wenn Konditionen festlegen mit
denen die Ukraine leben kann also die
Ukraine braucht einen starken Frieden
war militärische bat Situation
Russland nicht mehr weiterkommt und die
Ukraine auch gerne weiteren Erfolge
erzielen kann das ist die
Grundvoraussetzung Situation
ja ich glaube wir hatten mehrere Momente
auch im letzten Jahr wo man hätte
verhandeln können die ersten
Verhandlungen liefen ja März April
zwischen Ukraine und Russland dann gab
es auch nach der nach dem Abzug aus
vielleicht eine Gelegenheit und jetzt
natürlich auch damals gescheitert also
das kommt ja aus Israel diese Meldung da
von der Seite wird ja behaupte damals
lag alles auf dem Tisch und einige
Nato-Partner hätten das so heißt es von
dort ja nicht zu dem Zeitpunkt gewollt
naja ich glaube ich aus meiner Bewertung
haben vor allem der Amerikaner und die
Briten ist nicht gewollt weil sie auch
die
signaturmächte des Budapester
Memorandums sind von 1994 dass die
territorale Integrität der Ukraine
wir waren damals noch nicht so also es
war ab das ist ja schnell geht
haben sondern das ist ganz lange dauert
das stimmt aber das widersprach
natürlich dem Geist dieses Abkommens und
das deswegen konnten die beiden da nicht
ja sagen und deswegen hat man es eben
vom Tisch geholt denke ich also ich
meine realistischer ist das was dort
gesagt wird eine Verschwörung also ich
glaube wir sind im Augenblick einer Lage
das beide Seiten auch so hohe Bäume
geklettert sind das ist sehr schwer ist
sich ein Frieden vorzustellen ja und
erfahrungsgemäß ist es so es kommt nur
zu einem Friedensschluss eine Seite
zumindest schwächelt und gab es damals
den Moment also im März halten Sie das
für realistisch
es gab einen Moment und wenn zutrifft
was wir in den Medien hören dass die
Ukrainer bereit waren in Sachen don-bass
und auch in Sachen Creme vermisse
einzugehen das war ja nur die Grundidee
ich glaube schon dass damals der Chance
bestanden hätte aber die wurde eben halt
nicht genutzt man fragt sich das ist ja
eine irre mailung so und man liest es
und den kann eigentlich nicht sein ja
warum sollten die das nicht wollen
halten sie das äh sehr sagen gerade sie
halten das durchaus für realistisch aber
warum sollte jemand im Westen das nicht
gewollt haben
naja ich meine das waren Eroberungskrieg
jetzt der Russen ganz am Anfang
wurde ja deutlich dass die russische
Armee bei weitem nicht so stark war wie
man das ursprünglich angenommen hat und
ich glaube man hat darauf gehofft dass
die Ukraine sich erfolgreich zu Wehr
setzt was dann ja auch geschehen ist und
man hofft eben durch diese starke
Unterstützung der Ukraine ich glaube der
amerikanische Außenminister oder gesagt
auch Russland zu schwächen das muss man
ja auch sagen ist auch ein
amerikanisches Ziel das ist auch
gelungen das heißt dass die
Verhandlungsposition im nächsten Monaten
nach dem März eben besser wird
vorübergehend war das möglicherweise
auch der Fall ist es gibt ja böse
Stimmen die sagen mit 5%, das
amerikanischen verteilungshaushalt wir
groß dann 50% geschwächt jetzt das muss
man sehen wenn jetzt haben sie gerade
gesagt militärischer hat wird die
Voraussetzung sein um an die
verhandlungstische beide Seiten
zurückzubringen der Militär Historiker
Neitzel hat das so auf den Punkt
gebracht der hat in dieser Woche gesagt
na der Krieg ist ganz offen offenbar aus
Sicht der vor allen Dingen Russlands
noch nicht schrecklich genug
irgendwann gibt es einen Punkt an dem
auch Russland die russische Gesellschaft
sagen würde genug ist genug aber wo
dieser Punkt ist und wo der Punkt in der
Ukraine ist das wissen wir nicht und
leider muss ich sagen ich bin jetzt mal
ganz ganz direkt und sage es sind
wahrscheinlich leider noch nicht genug
Menschen gestorben um diesen Krieg zu
beenden das klingt schrecklich zynisch
aber hat er Recht hat darf ich
vielleicht kurz ergänzen sondern was
vorher gesagt wurde ich denke wir
sollten Sie ja vorsichtig sein und hier
die russischen narrative nicht so stark
aufzunehmen
denn es gehört zu den zentralien
russischen dass der Westen die
Verhandlungen scheitern ist ganz so ist
das nicht deswegen habe ich immer wieder
gefragt was sollte das Interesse sein
was sollte das Interesse sein der
Verhandlungen ansehen so ähm wollte
Russland ja den Waffenstillstand nicht
zustimmen sondern die Kampfhandlungen
weiterführen auch während der
Verhandlungen und zwar die beiden
verhandlungsmannschaften also von
ukraineischen und russischen Seite haben
sich auch sehr gut verstanden allerdings
ist scheit alles letztlich dann lade mir
Putin denn Russland verlangte zu diesem
Zeitpunkt von verlangt nach wie vor ein
diktatfrieden das heißt die Ukraine hat
alle russischen Forderungen zu erfüllen
ein wichtiger Punkt der vielleicht für
Westen ein Problem darstellt die
sogenannte endnazifizierung gehört dazu
die komplette Entmilitarisierung wenn
wir von einer sogenannten
elternifizierung sprechen so ist das
nichts anderes als der Wunsch Russlands
die politische Führung der Ukraine durch
eine russische Marionetten auszutauschen
so ist das es ist sehr einfach erklärt
das ist sehr logischerweise nicht zu
erfüllen Seite selbstverständlich was
finden Westen mitunter ein Problem
gewesen sein könnte ist das die Ukraine
sehr weitreichende Sicherheitsgarantien
forderte und die im Grunde genommen
einen NATO Beitritt gleich kennen
praktischen arbeitet es ist aber noch
lange kein Grund zu sagen der Westen hat
die Verhandlungen scheitern lassen das
war mit Sicherheit nicht der Fall das
heißt sie sagen die Argumentation Mensch
der jetzt die Möglichkeit gegeben im
März das ist im Grunde
sagen Sie mal die Möglichkeit hat uns
gegeben aber es scheiterte an Moskau ja
jetzt reden wir gerade über die
Möglichkeit an den Verhandlungstisch
zurückzukehren hey du WoW und ich habe
ihn gerade die Aussage von
Militärhistoriker synkanalzel gezeigt
der sagt ganz zynisch gesagt es sind
einfach noch nicht genügend Tote auf dem
Schlachtfeld gestorben genügend Menschen
auf dem Schlachtfeld gestorben es müsste
der Krieg noch schrecklicher werden vor
allen Dingen für Russland damit sie
gezwungen sind an den Verhandlungstisch
zu gehen
wesentlich schreckliche kamen diese
Krieg für die Ukraine nicht mehr werden
da wir sollten bedenken wie viele
Kriegsverbrechen nachgewiesenen bereits
zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt nachgewiesen
gegangen hat verstehen
davon sprechen die die russischen
Führungszeugnis
über was die Schrecken für Russland
haben belangt wie wie wie bereits gesagt
der Krieg ist Blumen Köpfen der
Russinnen und Russen nicht angekommen
und das wird auch lange nicht der Fall
sein denn aktuell
bemüht sich die russische Propaganda
damit dieser Krieg auch nicht ankommt
ich will das nur noch mal aufgreifen
weil das ja auch darauf zielt was sie
sagen es muss militärisches Patt geben
jetzt sagt so im kanalzel es ist noch
nicht schrecklich genug zumindest dann
für Russland noch nicht das heißt unsere
westlichen Waffen müssten noch tödlicher
sein müssten mehr Schrecken verbreiten
damit Putin einlenkt man das Leid in den
Familien ist schon enorm groß es gibt
Dörfer da gibt es keine Männer mehr
unter 25 und dafür gibt es einen Grund
dass es nicht öffentlich ist weil die
gesamte Social Media
Öffentlichkeitsarbeit ist eingestellt
weil es gibt keine Opposition mehr keine
Interesse die darüber berichtet und das
ist doch mehr ein Indiz dafür was Putin
hat und deswegen wird es jetzt auch kein
Waffenstillstand geben denn er würde
diese Chance nur nutzen sich
aufzufrischen zu stärken und dann nach
links oder rechts auszuweichen große
Sorge der baltischen Staaten ja ich frag
so zynisch weil das möglicherweise ja
war es was der Militärhistoriker sagt
sie müssen die Ukraine mit westlicher
Unterstützung noch mehr töten damit
Putin an den verhandlungstischen das ist
das so das sehe ich nicht so sondern es
geht darum die Ukraine zu stärken zu
unterstützen im militärischen Vorgehen
nämlich den russischen möglichen
Offensive zurückzudrängen und Gebiet
zurück zu erobern aber irgendwann werden
die Mütter der gefallenen russischen
Soldaten aufstehen und diese sogenannte
spezialoperation wirklich benennen als
eine andere Person
Russland lange lange drauf warten nein
ich fühlte das ist nicht so oder können
wir sehr lange darauf warten die die
wesentliche Frage ist die politischen
Proteste am aktuellen Russland absolut
keine Chance der einzige von Gott ist
die Regierung gefährlich werden könnte
sind sozial motivierte Proteste und dazu
müsste der Lebensstandard oder die
gewohnte Lebensführung der Bevölkerung
enorm und sich sehr schnell nach unten
verändert sich enorm verschlechtern und
zwar da können beispielsweise die
Sanktionen dazu sehr stark beitragen
darüber reden wir dass es genau das
Stichwort wir haben jetzt lange über das
militärische über die Stärke oder
Schwäche der putinischen Armee
gesprochen wollen einmal über die
Wirkung der Sanktionen sprechen ganz
wichtig vom ersten Kriegstag an
beschlossen auf EU-Ebene und es hieß
sofort kraftvolle Sanktionen
mittlerweile geht man in die zehnte
Stufe dieser Sanktion und die
EU-Kommissarin sagt man habe die
russische Wirtschaft ganz erheblich
geschwächt ist es so ja nicht also wenn
man sich die Zahlen angesagt kann man
den Eindruck gewinnen kurzfristig nicht
wobei mit Statistik und zahlen wäre ich
immer sehr vorsichtig die müssen nicht
stimmen aus Moskau ganz im Gegenteil ich
glaube nur an die Statistik die sich
selbst gefälscht habe
aber der der Rubel etwas so angeblich
wie Krieg gehen
russische Wirtschaft schlägt sich besser
als erwartet das kann man schon so sagen
Mittel langfristig sieht das anders aus
weil ich glaube die russische Wirtschaft
war immer sehr stark auf die enge
Zusammenarbeit mit westlichen Firmen mit
dem Westen angewiesen das ging über den
Gas also mittellangfristig sagen
zusammenbrechen würde ich nicht sagen
sie leiden darunter das kostet
Wirtschaftswachstum das kostet
Zukunftsperspektiven ich glaube das ist
das entscheidende ich glaube kein
Zusammenbruch den den sehe ich mir dafür
gibt es die ganzen Rohstoffreserven das
können wir weiter für äußern nach Asien
auch andere Gegend ich glaube in
Zusammenbruch ist nicht zu erwarten aber
eine Verlangsamung natürlich das
Wachstums und auch einen aber das klingt
doch so wenn wir so viel Worte brauchen
um die Wirkung unserer Sanktionen zu
beschreiben dass sie nicht die Wirkung
hatten ganz offenbar hat die man
beabsichtigt hat ab dem Kriegsbeginn
ja das stimmt aber ich möchte noch mal
kurz was zu diesem abnutzungsgedanken
sagen den der vorne heute ich finde
diese Diskussion es sind nicht genug
gestorben es müssen noch mehr sterben
absurd der amerikanische
generalstoffchef hat gesagt 200.000
gefallen auf beiden Seiten 50.000
ziviltote Millionen Flüchtlinge wir
haben das Beispiel von
abnutzungsschlachten aus dem ersten
Weltkrieg vor bergdo sind fast eine
Million junger phantosen und deutscher
gefallen von nothing weil dieser
abnutzungsgedanke wie sind genau sagt
auf beiden Seiten so transparent so
wichtig so gewichtig war dass sie
annahmen da führen wir die Entscheidung
dabei wir nutzen und so weit ab bis der
andere nicht mehr kann und in dieser
Phase sind wir im Moment in der Ukraine
und das ist das fürchterliche brutale
was man einfach sehen muss und wo man
rauskommen muss dann bleiben wir noch im
Moment dabei erfahren
Stück weit ertappt weil das natürlich im
Moment genau das ist was stattfindet auf
beiden Seiten ungefähr Ballons bisschen
hin bisschen zurück zurück immer
eigentlich derselbe der dasselbe
Schlachtfeld auf beiden Seiten einen
brutaler abnutzungskrieg jetzt haben wir
gehört ungefähr 5000 Tote pro Woche auf
beiden Seiten und kein Ausweg ist das
möglicherweise auch das erklärte Ziel
genau diesen abnutzungskrieg länger zu
ziehen nein Russland weiter zu schwächen
nein das darf es nicht sein das ist auch
nicht unser Interesse es ist klarer
Bruch des Völkerrechts es ist ein
Angriffskrieg und wir dürfen dem
stärkeren nicht nachgeben sondern das
Recht muss oder umgesetzt werden weil
die gesamte europäische Friedensordnung
wird damit angegriffen aber wir wollen
ja auch ein Zeichen setzen zu sagen es
wird sich nicht lohnen für Russland eine
neue Offensive beispielsweise
brauchen Sie noch mehr Waffen müssen sie
noch brutaler vorgehen müssen Sie den
fein konsequenter zurückdrängen dort in
der Ukraine sagen sie auch nein das
heißt sie sie bleiben ja genau bei
dieser Balance bei diesem Abnutzung ich
sage wir müssen auf dem Gefechts
überlegen sein deswegen ist ja auch die
panzerdebatte weil man eben eine Feuer
Überlegenheit erzielen muss die Ukraine
in die Situation zu versetzen sich auch
erfolgreich wehren zu können damit die
nächste Offensive hoffentlich nicht
kommt sehen Sie hier den Ausweg aus
diesem abnutzungskrieg Herfahrt den sie
gerade so emotional kritisiert haben
also ich denke sie halt die militärische
Ausweglosigkeit wenn wir das
Weitermachen ja dann sterben tausende
jeden Tag ne aber wir schaffen es nicht
da rauszukommen dieser Krieg ist
militärisch nicht entscheidbar das heißt
wir schaffen keine militärische Lösung
dann müssen wir unsere vor weiteren
Waffen liefern mal definieren welche
politischen Ziele wir haben das ist ja
eben angesprochen worden wollen wir die
Ukraine in die Lage versetzen dombas und
können zurückzuerobern wollen wir Sie in
die Lage versetzen Russland entscheiden
zu schlagen oder wollen wir sie so weit
stabilisieren dass die Voraussetzung für
Verhandlungen möglich ist die können
nicht realistisch also wer ist wir wir
sind natürlich Deutschland als Teil der
Europäischen Union und der NATO aber am
Ende muss es auch das Bundeskabinett
deutlich mal sagen wofür wir stehen das
ist rein exekutives handeln und da hat
der Deutsche Bundestag dem Kabinett die
Möglichkeit gegeben Waffen zu liefern
und ich kritisiere noch mal nicht nur
das immer zu spät debattiert wir sind
das einzelne Waffensysteme gefährdet und
was fehlt teilweise ist eine Strategie
zu sagen was will Europa zugestimmt im
Bundestag
Überzeugung wie sie gerade sagen nur sie
haben den zugestimmt ohne zu wissen was
mit den Leoparden auf dem sie selbst
übrigens saßen in ihrer in ihrer Zeit
bei der Bundeswehr sie haben dem
zugestimmt die Leoparden zu schicken
ohne zu wissen was damit passieren soll
nein es ist doch ganz klar wozu die da
sind nämlich die nächste Offensive
abzuwehren aber Strategie gesagt ihn
fehlt die Strategie die Strategie
Europas fehlt mir ja wir diskutieren
über einzelne Systeme und dies
orientiert sich aber auch am Willen des
ukrainischen Volkes sondern der
Strategie silenskys und da sagt er ganz
klar zurückbringen das ähm russischen
Vormarsches bis vielleicht auf die Linie
24 februar und zu vermeiden dass die
nächste Großoffensive Russlands Erfolg
hat und deswegen hoffentlich nicht
startet wenn Sie das Hören jetzt ist der
Orte nicht Teil des Bundeskabinetts
kritisiert das Schaf dafür dass das eben
nicht so klar ausgesprochen ist sie als
Wissenschaftler verzweifeln Sie nicht
daran dass man so große Anstrengung
mittlerweile wirtschaftlich
finanziell ja auch für uns alle und dann
aber eben auch militärisch unternimmt
ohne die große Strategie nun zugespielt
formuliert frieden gibt es nicht zu
Nulltarif und zu dessen sollten wir uns
bewusst sein das ist mir der erste Punkt
der zweite Punkt ist strategischen
Zielsetzungen sind von US amerikanischen
Präsidenten Joseph beiden im Mai
vergangenen Jahres in der New York Times
sondern Leitartikel vorgeschlagen worden
und zwar ging es darum war um die
Stärkung der Ukraine bis eine
militärische bazsituation erreichen und
den Beitrag jetzt mal auf einen Satz
zusammen zu kürzen
sollten wir tatsächlich wollen dass zu
Ende geht kann der Krieg bereits morgen
zu Ende gehen wir müssen nur heute damit
aufhören die Ukraine zu unterstützen der
Winterkrieg sehr schnell zu Ende gehen
wirklich sehr schnell ja
Ergebnis glücklich sein werden
so wie sie Herfahrt gesagt haben dann
wird das täglich tausende Tote Ukraine
geben denn wir brauchen nur unseren
Blick darauf zu richten wie es dann der
ukrainischen Bevölkerung in den von
Russland teil besetzten Gebieten geht
das ist reinster Völkermarkt oder
zumindest sind wir bereits in der
Schwelle zum Völkermarkt unzählige
Kriegsverbrechen diese wäre am Ende der
Kriegshandlungen nicht aufhören sondern
die werden erst richtig beginnen und wir
sollten auch nicht vergessen wie viele
Kinder von der Rosen vom von Russland
führt wurden und zu zwangsreduktion
freigegeben wurden also wenn das kein
Völkermarkt ist dann bitte definieren
Sie Völkermord also wir sollten hier
sehr sehr vorsichtig sein dass ich denke
dass eine militärische bazsituation auf
jeden Fall sehr strebenswert ist diese
wird das aber ohne die Unterstützung der
Ukraine durch den